- Alright everybody, happy weekend,
we are going to play Five
Questions for Evan and Nina.
(playful music)
Okay so this is a spur
of the moment thing,
Nina doesn't really even
know what we're doing,
here's what we're going to do:
I pulled up this list of 200 questions
to get to know somebody, and I'm
going to pick five to ask you,
and you're going to pick five to ask me,
and we'll go one at a time.
- About yourself?
- No about the other person.
I pick one for you, you pick one for me.
Alright, ready?
Your question is, let's see,
what's your favorite piece of clothing
that you own or have owned?
- Oh one of that dress from
bee-see beachy, very elegant.
- Okay that was an easy one, I'm soft,
but that wasn't very
detailed though, Nina,
okay we want some comedy,
okay, find a question for me.
♫ Do do do do do do do
We have to do this five times, you know,
we got to, you got to pick
some questions! (laughs)
- What songs have you
completely memorized?
- The most memorable one
was this Chinese song,
I don't remember it now anymore.
- Oh!
- But there's this Chinese song
that I wanted to impress Nina
with one of her favorite songs
and so I had a friend of mine write out
how it would sound in English,
and then I would memorize it,
I had no idea what it was saying,
and then I had Nina play
it in the car randomly,
it came on randomly and then
I just started singing to her.
Do you remember any of it?
(singing in Chinese)
(laughing)
Yeah, what what?
(singing in Chinese)
(Nina laughs)
I'm making stuff up now,
that was pretty good,
come on that's like three years!
- You had to sing it at our wedding.
- I was forced to.
Next question, what job
would you be terrible at?
- Oh be-ki, I don't know,
can you just ask me another question?
- (laughing) No, answering
questions, that's the challenge.
- I don't know.
I've never done a job that was really bad.
- Maybe you haven't done enough jobs.
- I've done a lot of jobs.
- How about (laughs) how about a clown?
I think you'd be a real bad clown.
- Oh I would be really bad
at making people laugh.
- Nina would be a really bad clown.
- [Nina] I, I, yeah.
- Nina would be a bad clown.
- I'm very, I'm very--
- Don't dress up as a clown.
- Reserved.
- Okay, clown, okay, good.
(Nina laughs)
I answered your question
for you, okay good.
Go next, okay, two, we got
to get through five each,
come on this going to--
- Okay, what would your
perfect room look like?
- My perfect room look like?
My perfect room, hm.
My perfect room would
have my YouTube channel
playing on my big screen TV (laughing)
with daily, with second by the
second updates and comments,
it would have this
awesome ice cream machine
that would be like no calorie ice cream.
(Nina laughs)
And soft serve orange swirl, oh my god.
And it would have all sorts of toppings
that were also low calorie,
no calorie toppings
that I could include with it.
There would be a big picture
of Nina somewhere in there.
- That's somber okay, you
don't even have the picture.
- Its important.
I feel like a bean bag is important.
What else would I need to have?
I need to have my video
camera ready to go.
I think like one of those eight
screen monitors, you know?
Like a computer with like eight monitors
that have different things
on them, it'd be pretty cool.
An infinity pool that you could jump into.
The pool that you could jump into
that like when you swim it moves.
- In the same room?
- Yeah in the same room of course,
with an infinity view so that
it's like, it's going out ...
That goes outside!
Okay so like the office is
enclosed but there's like
this secret part on the side
with an outdoor above ground,
like, and this is like sky rise, right,
so you're going out
and you've got 360 view
and the water's pushing back,
you got to swim against it.
That'd be pretty cool.
A direct phone line to Batman
would also be very cool.
(Nina laughs)
I think, I don't know.
That would be an essential
part of an ideal room.
That's pretty good that's a
good start, that's a good start,
I feel like I'd need a
teleportation somewhere,
or just like I could jump into a tube
when it like transports me
somewhere, that'd be really good.
- That must be a huge room.
- No, no, but it's all
going to be condensed,
like everything has its own spot.
- I just noticed, you
did lose a lot of weight,
your bone, your cheekbone
is very, it's showing a lot.
- Okay, you should be a clown.
Okay, good!
- Oh my god yeah you lost too much weight!
- Too much weight, la, you
know that's what happens.
Okay, next, what pets did you have
while you were growing up?
You had dogs!
- (mumbles) All the
dogs that my Mom bought,
they will last for one season. (laughs)
- Oh wow.
- Because, er ...
(Evan mumbles)
(laughing)
(Evan coughs)
- Because when I was in China I was living
like quite a big street that's like--
- (coughing loudly) Go on!
- Different lanes, four lane street,
it's like our houses right
by the big main street.
Every time, like, almost
every year, every time--
- I'm not letting your
Mom babysit the dog.
- No because those dogs
they're not like pets
like in Canada.
- They didn't last, they
got ran over by car.
What takes too much of your time? (laughs)
Your time is valuable.
- You know, I'm in charge of my time,
so I take accountability for the things
that take up too much of my time.
I would say driving, driving
takes too much of my time,
I don't like driving.
Picking people up,
driving people to places.
It's also because it's hard to
be productive while driving.
I can't do anything
else while I'm driving.
Guess I could still talk
to people on the phone
if I use the phone.
Anything else I don't mind so much
because I can usually get work done,
I can do something, I can be productive.
When I'm driving, I can't, it bothers me.
What are some small things
that make your day better?
That's when you pick me up somewhere
and drive me to something! (laughs)
- Driving.
- Yeah.
- Great.
(Nina laughs)
Don't pretend, it's only five minutes
to drive me somewhere, okay?
(Evan coughs and sighs)
Okay, you get to spend
time with your wife.
Only on the way there, and
then I have to spend time--
- Yeah and then you get to
spend time with your dog
on the way back.
- I have the dog the whole day!
- Well but he was sleeping during the day.
Okay, next, my go.
- That's it, the only thing
that makes your day better
is when I drive you to the subway mark?
- What are some small things,
so this is some of it, not all!
- Okay, alright, fine.
- Okay?
- Okay, question four for
me, what have you got?
- What shows are you into?
- What shows am I into?
- Yeah.
- What kind of shows, like TV shows?
So together we're
watching Game of Thrones,
we're watching Agents of Shield.
- Blindspot.
- Oh yeah and blindspot
we went through that,
we went through Gotham,
we went through Suits,
- And Arrow.
- We went through Arrow.
- Flash.
- We watch like one show a
night, one episode a night,
feels like, how have we
gone through so much stuff?
Arrow, Flash, and then me,
also watch Billions and Silicon Valley.
- Yeah, I don't like them.
- No Nina doesn't watch them.
And then every now and then
like a backup sharktank
or the Prophet, the Prophet was good too.
- Yeah I liked Prophet.
- Yeah.
- What's his name?
- Mac-is-son mon-o-reece.
Okay, last question, oh my
God it better be a good one.
Last question, what are you interested in
that most people haven't heard of?
- Oh my God I don't know,
that should be me asking you!
- Good question, (laughs)
I got that question I'm so excited!
- I don't know.
- Final answer!
- I don't know, you just pick another one.
- The bachata dancing.
How about something Chinese?
What do you do that's Chinese that, er,
you watch Chinese TV shows.
- I watch a lot of Chinese TV shows
when Evan's not available.
V Channel, V Channel.
- She orders a lot of stuff.
- No.
- Lot of Chinese boxes
arrive, often to the Condo.
- (laughs) That was your,
those boxes they're for you.
- A lot of random clothes showing up.
What else do you do that
most people haven't heard of?
- I don't think most people
have heard of bachata dancing,
come on you guys, you don't
know what bachata dancing is.
Maybe key-zumba dancing?
- No.
- Okay we'll go with bachata dancing.
- I'm a very simple person.
- Last question for me!
♫ Last question for me
What have you got, Nina?
I like this one, if you are a dictator
of a small island nation,
what crazy dictator stuff would you do?
I like the office one, I'm
excited for my infinity edge pool
auto-motion out into the city
with my direct line to Batman.
- What piece of entertainment do you wish
you could erase from your
mind so that you could
experience for the first time again?
- Oh wow!
What was a great first experience?
See the experience often is
around the circumstances too.
- Rollercoaster?
- I don't want to experience it again.
If I could just erase it from
my mind, that'd be great,
but then I ave to experience
it again for the first time,
so see the problem is a
lot of the first time,
you know, that's a good experience,
you can't recreate those circumstances.
- Okay, let me ask another one.
- What, really?
- Yeah.
- I was thinking about that one!
- Okay maybe you could come
back later if you want.
- No it's only, that's the last question!
Okay, are you going to switch it up?
- What movie title best
describes your life? (laughs)
- What movie title best describes my life?
Why are you laughing?
Is there some movie called believe?
(Nina laughs)
There's got to be a movie called believe,
that's an easy one.
I'm curious you guys, what
movie title best describes me,
or this channel?
- This is asking you!
- Yeah I know, I know, but
I'm just asking, you know,
its an interactive thing here.
The Bourne Identity!
I'll go with the Bourne identity.
- Okay.
- Oh boy.
Wait are you flexing in the camera?
(laughing and coughing)
My wife the clown.
- Jason Bourne?
- Yeah I don't even know
why I picked that one.
- Why?
- I don't know, I have no idea,
I just said I don't know
why I picked that one.
I watched it the other
day when I was sick.
- Yeah I saw you watched it.
- The newest one, it was okay.
(phone beeps)
There you go, The Bourne Identity.
Alright, you guys watching,
if you had to pick
a movie title to describe this channel,
who is it, what is it,
leave in the comments below.
Thank you guys so much for watching,
hope you're having an amazing weekend,
let us know what you're
thinking about this new
spur of the moment kind of
video for life with Evan.
We believe in you, hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love guys, we'll see you soon!